We're back in the game I don't know what happened, it crashed, it broke my whole Elgato recording software.
I'm blue now.
This Beth is different.
She still talk like she out of breath, beth.
Seems like it.
Where's what?
Got my gun.
He doesn't. Oh, she still talks the same.11 fucking years.
Yard worker, I don't hear anyone, why are they subtitled?
Riding Beth!
So the person we're discussing everything with is from Monarch, apparently.
So I assume that the brother takes over Monarch, and not the African American man.
Ok, I'm over here, by the way.
Hey hey!
What is the countermeasure? I don't know.
Probably in here.And I have to find a way to get there.
Maybe they should remove, you know what they should do, they should remove the floor so you can see, anything. That's what they should do.
They should, take everything away.
Oh yeah we have been here before you're right.
Some are yet to come.
Beth, how you doing bae.
The code is.
Ooooohhhh shit!
Oooohhh!
Then why did you do shit.
God she looks creepy she's like a fucking dead skeleton.
From hell.
And that's not a compliment.
*mutters*
Alright, deal with the Monarch threat, okay.
Guess I'll do that.
I got a feeling she's gonna get taken anyway.
Oh she's just chilling in the back.
What seems to be the problem?
What seems to be the problem!
Oh this is before they like got any powers and shit.
Suprise bitch!
This should be easy.
Annd there!
Hey hey, look at that.
I'll take a gun.
If you don't mind.
Yeah what's the sit rep.
I'm tearing their assholes.
If I could learn how to aim.
Suprise!
How do you fucking survive a shotgun blast from point blank range.
Now we get to the point of the game where the game is like, we need more hours.
How do we make it longer.
Thank you.
Ohhh!
That's how you do it.
All right.
I am furiated!
*whispers*
Get out of my way...
Beth has gotta be taken!
*singing*
Hey, we are back here!
Why does he want it?
It was a cube all along?
Get it, Jack, you gotta catch it Jack!
Oh!
That activates it?!
Dropping it on the ground?
That doesn't seem like a very good design, whoever did it.
Listen, guys, it's just a disco!
Why am i talking to you then?
WHAT?
Beth, come on...